and you love the ocean I understand I
love that yeah I my father raised me
around the ocean and I was scuba diving
and by the time I was ten you know I was
fishing ever since I could hold a pole
and so I I lived in Hawaii for a while
and I've served for 25 years and scuba
dive and all that sort of things yeah
any analogy and surfing that applies to
navigating an acting career Oh easily I
love seeing all these people now that
you know they're all surfers you know
Matthew McConaughey but I understand why
I do because you can only be in the
moment it's like rock climbing I used to
be a rock climber as well you can only
be in the moment when you're doing that
or you're gonna get in you're just gonna
wipe out in not such a good way and one
has to feel the the motion of the nature
of the beast that you're on and so yeah
I learned a lot a lot about endurance
and and keeping my eyes open
certainly
you